ماذا يعني العاروري بالنسبه لاسرائيل
ولماذا استهدافه والمخاطره حتى لو في
لبنان وفي الضاحيه الجنوبيه لكن العاروري
تحديدا
لماذا يعني اولا فيما يتعلق بالشيخ صالح
العروره التحريض الاسرائيلي ضد الشيخ صالح
العروره قديم يعني سابق على عمليه سبعه
تشرين اكتوبر الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يحمل
الشيخ صالح العروره المسؤوليه عن العديد
من اعمال المقاومه داخل ساحه الضفه
الغربيه ولا سما ان الشيخ صالح العرور هو
رئيس اقليم الضفه الغربيه في حركه حماس
بالاضافه الى كونه نائبا لرئيس حركه حماس
بالاضافه الى ذلك الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يحمل ايضا الشيخ صالح العاروري المسؤوليه
عن عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي قامت
بها حركه حماس انطلاقا من الساحه
اللبنانيه باتجاه فلسطين المحتله ليس فقط
في سياق هذه الحرب العدوانيه التي يشنها
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على الفلسطينيين في
قطاع غزه ولكن قبل ذلك في سياق تصعيد حاله
المقاومه التي كانت موجوده في الضفه
الغربيه وما تزال موجوده وايضا في سياق
الدفاع عن المسجد الاقصى والرد على
اقتحامات المستوطنين الاسرائيليين للمسجد
الاقصى منذ ذلك الوقت يعني منذ فتره طويله
والاحتلال الاسرائيلي يحرض على الشيخ صالح
العروره بعد عمليه س تشرين اكتوبر وتعثر
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في حربه العدوانيه
على الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه بدا الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن ان قيادات حركه حماس
خارج فلسطين المحتله لن يكونوا امنين في
اي مكان من هذه الاماكن طبعا اذا نظرنا
الى الشيخ صالح العروره بالاضافه الى هذه
التهديدات وهذا التحريض السابق على عمليه
7 تشرين اكتوبر فنحن نتحدث عن قياده من
الوزن الثقيل يعني هذا واحد من اكبر
قيادات حركه حماس على الاطلاق مسؤول ساحه
كبيره جدا في حركه حماس داخل فلسطين ونائب
رئيس حركه حماس واضح تماما انه يتولى
العديد من الملفات المهمه على مستوى حركه
حماس وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن اغتيال كبير
من وزن اغتيال الشيخ احمد ياسين ام من وزن
اغتيال الدكتور عبد العزيز نيسي ومن ثم
هذه واحده من اضخم عمليات الاغتيال التي
تعرضت لها حركه حماس فاذا كان المقصود
الشيخ صالح العروره على وجه الخصوص وعلى
وجه التحديد انا اعتقد ان هذه هي الاهداف
وهذه هي الاسباب بالدرجه الاولى المتعلقه
بشخصه على وجه الخصوص لكن بالتاكيد في
هناك اهداف اخرى ارادها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من هذه العمليه من ضمن ذلك
الخروج بصوره انتصار وهو ما كنا نتحدث عنه
من ضمن ذلك خلط الاوراق في الحقيقه وربما
محاوله استفزاز حزب او جس النبض ومحاوله
القول انه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان اذرعه
ممتده وانه قادر ان يضرب في كل مكان وان
احدا لا يستطيع ان يكف يد الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهذه رساله موجهه من المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه عموما السياسيه والعسكريه
والامنيه الى المجتمع الاسرائيلي الى
الاقليم العربي ثمت اراده لتكريس الهيمنه
الاسرائيليه في المنطقه وفي الاقليم بعدما
اهتزت هذهه الهيمنه بفعل عمليه سبعه تشرين
اكتوبر من داخل قطاع غزه نعم